we start off this real big with a lot of
energy that's what we like here my gosh
we're so lucky we're lucky today are
very lucky how many studios cover
Charlie I'm Kevin and we're lucky we
have Lana Turner in the house I'm the
lucky one seriously thanks a lot this is
great so you upon you get here I mean
you you you talked to karissa and yeah
we hooked it up through the HTC
connection it's an egg TCK TCK now see
that's the benefit of being on the ATC
no it's great yeah now this is awesome
coolest yeah we've been trying to get
you on since your podcast started which
was what six months ago whoa that's it's
deceiving cuz we had the podcast for a
year and then we let it go for a little
while so we have like all these old
episodes that we put back up and then
we've been doing it we're almost up on a
year now okay so yeah we've been trying
to do it for your basically cool um
we're not consistent with our scheduling
no hardly brothers it's really her it's
really the Farley brothers you know I
I'm always make it a little harder uh
yeah take it a little bit hard yeah
we're not as consistent I'm always gone
this summer in particular you were gone
up to hun yeah anyway we apologize it
took so long to get you here but so
happy you're here yeah hey now what else
what's good let's just go bone about
that the whole time yes you in your
podcast what's up no my husband and I
have it together so he's a comedian as
well you actually will Ralphie May now
if he's your husband oh yeah for now
okay for now yeah but Ralphie's on the
road a lot he's on the road all the time
I see him out of the bus and I see him
in Iowa I saw a decent the bus I've seen
the bus oh wow I saw how house was like
maybe a year ago yeah we're ready but I
actually love going to Iowa cuz you can
eat the air it's so clean hey but the
fact that you ran into him on his buses
that screen no I didn't run into him I
just saw the bus yeah he was coming in
after I got done with a diamond Joe
casino in hindu guy along and then
Ralphie was rolling in with his bus
after I left oh but uh I think yeah I
see him out there all the time
I mean he's got the bus that's all he
does he's just on the road yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's doing great though God
and so how long you guys been married
we've just got finished our 10-year
anniversary in yeah that's great we've
been together for 17 years 17 yeah how
do you think the separation helps or
hurts oh that's an interesting thing
today look at that going right at you at
that one right at you without we're
happy it's hard man like it is um yeah
and we've had a rough summer and you
know it I don't know man it's it's this
is not fun well no it is this
conversation cuz we've been having a lot
of trouble lately oh yeah talk about
that's okay but like the set that the
road is tough I used to go to him all
the time on the road and that was
challenging so we just were just
figuring out yeah it's art of the family
to somebody kids you guys we have to
yeah yeah so is it little there's their
pretty little their six and seven oh
they're awesome they're like the best
things ever yeah I start at school
Rebecca yeah they're back in school
which is great too because that means i
have two more time starts now right this
school start at like two weeks ago
almost yeah oh that's great it starts
early now yeah really early really early
or is your kid in school she's in
preschool or still on break oh yeah the
preschool is Lee kind of mess you up and
you have to pay a lot more yes oh yeah
we're still on break so it's the
elevator how old is yours 40 that's the
best I know for is really fun and yeah
it's pretty great cuz we just I just
dumped her at her friend's house today
is like they're old enough now or she
can do a play date and I don't have to
be there oh that's cool super great
jumper off of that special uncle yep it
don't worry things gonna be fun
everything's fun I told her about her
own body part she knows what a vagina is
everything's fine Oh Lord well you know
that's what they say like you should
tell them the problem James to them and
she's forced as she met his will learn
how to use it yeah there you go she did
actually say the other day she's been
really liking to sleep naked cuz it's
hot in her house and she did say like
don't worry mama I'm just touching my
vagina yeah that's like right yeah my my
son um we have an babysitter that's cute
and he's like mommy Megan's boobies make
my pee pee tingle
yeah we already yes and I will for a
limit that get used to it yes Megan's
boobies are now fried on your brain yeah
you'll be looking at Megan's boobies for
the rest of your life okay yeah so funny
surbhi tingle what if I said they do hey
baby yeah i just gotta say this a great
restaurant isn't really your boobies
make my TV if she takes you home then
you gotta worry i usually make oh I like
the P key jingle OH movies really make
my BP tango hilarious haha one time I
was in a public restroom with him and
he's sitting on the potty doing his
business and he yells out mommy my
peepees growing and I here like three
women just crack up hahaha I don't know
you be hilarious as an adult to do yeah
just yeah I'm bad with a girl you go wow
why why is this happening like and then
when you come to go get really freaked
out when I come what the [ __ ] were dead
what the [ __ ] would ya would you make me
dude I hurt myself I love and laying my
[ __ ] heart my job well you may we go
is the reason like you know deleted
scenes from big big deleted scene yea
big delizia who's gonna be our yea big
was gonna be I me like oh my god well
[ __ ] is that k my way
comments having gasps oh my god but then
you have to end that sentence mommy why
why I gotta call my mommy something
happened you made me do some damage call
my mom call your mom go I mommy mommy I
with this girl say hello to my mommy Oh
mrs. Farley she made me do something my
BP grew and then something came out of
that oh well you're my light what did
you do what did she do let me talk to
her talk to her what are you doing to my
son mrs. Farley something I [ __ ] up
here no you're [ __ ] up get out of
there my friend are my Adelaide's little
friend her older brothers just turned 12
and they were talking about how his like
he's getting like puffy nipples you know
like he is kind of like in that way that
you don't like when you're like 12 13
yeah I said yeah boobs yeah happy hey
honey coffee temple oh my gosh no no
huberty is frightening so scary I had
the worst puberty of all what happened I
was the stinky smelly girl in junior
high guide the armpit hair like you know
straight up armpit hair like yeah nobody
you think it was that bad oh no it was
that bad I was that we moved from Canada
to Texas and like nobody was paying
attention puberty hit that summer
started at a new junior high had no
friends walked in nobody yeah nobody sat
me down and did the whole hey this is
deodorant this is a yeah yeah how'd you
have her parents I mean yeah oh yeah
where were they I
oh I knew that like yeah sometimes they
just let that sit stuff slide oh my mom
was so she you know to this day she
can't really talk about stuff but I mean
she ordered like there was like an
insert in Seventeen magazine we could
like send away for a start a period
starter kit Oh what it was like a came
with me it was like a box that came in
the mail like six weeks later and it was
like a tampon and a pad and some like
brochures and that she just handed me
the box and fit said you figure this out
my mom did something very similar yet
yeah that's that's crazy you gotta sit
down the taxi hey I don't think back in
the old days my dad I remember going to
we had a parent teacher I mean a parent
kid the sex education class where dad
came with me ooh said dr. Doherty drew a
big penis on the chalkboard and my dad
pokes me goes here look at that thing
I'm looking at him gone you're like
worse than me did you go in he's like no
we drove a giant and my dad vagina god I
go dead stop it I like I'm in fifth
grade and he's laughing giggling about
the doctor trying you to this this
classroom setting to ya so that he
didn't have to talk to you about it yeah
he was just like well no the the school
offered it they like you can bring your
dad so it just lets the parents off the
hook cuz i'm going to that itíll be
great yeah talk about talk about it so
we just sit in class let the doctor talk
about it so the doctor drew like
everything on the board put down
diagrams and my dad's giggling giggling
out loud like I almost got in trouble
the animals got in trouble that's so
funny gets kicked out yeah my daughter
who is very young to have asked what she
asked about the birds and the bees and
it was precipitated by the fact that she
was at school and she was singing my
anaconda in my god dot Mon unless you
got buns hun and another little girl
said well that's about a PP and it's the
same age but she's an older brother and
my daughters like no it's not it's a
snake and they ended up getting in a
fight she a little girl and the teacher
to intervene and then my
honor had to come home and ask me why
she got in trouble and so I had to
explain to her that the Anaconda was
actually add you know like it's poetry
yeah and she said but I don't understand
I look well the Anaconda or the boy
likes the big booty I'd like literally
tell her I explained because of that
song yeah hop news yeah she said that
that's another one putt there was
another song that my brother had to
explain cuz he's like and then we did it
in the bathroom and then what you say
and then we did it in the thong i freak
you know that song yeah yeah it wasn't
me it wasn't me and then we did it he's
like well I think one lyric is like an
that effector and it's like so hot in
there my brothers like what though what
the [ __ ] hey yo and their kids are
singing it all over the house and then I
[ __ ] they were in the bathroom in the
sidewalk it wasn't me are you singing
what is that song and it's like it's all
over the radio oh it's like whoa [ __ ]
does that ever just like and then I
[ __ ] her in the bath and [ __ ] her in
the shower [ __ ] her this my brothers
like we've lost our goddamn line on the
radio and worst of all the songs
teaching them to lie right right yeah
lied it wasn't in the bathroom you admit
that you it don't be a chair exactly
first part have all the horrible song
when I thought during the bat wasn't me
and the other girls just creepy watching
in every room yeah I wasn't mean I
wasn't mean yeah horrible tune oh I'm
teaching kids anything did your
brother's not tell you anything like did
you learn stuff I learned from Leo Perna
and Playboy I remember picking up a
Playboy and Leo poorna told me how to
whack off my friend yeah he's like you
play around and stuff comes up he that
that's out here you know you that's the
way you figured it out as you play your
buddies hanging out and then they go
there's just think I'll Playboy and we
we used to go stall one you know from
this from the store and we looked at it
right look now how I wonderful how many
guys have that server they stole the
Playboy in this shopkin sees them and
just
go ahead I don't draw off there's
probably like in them in the budget in
the line I am it's just like play boys
four young boys but I me now come don't
easy oh I know I mean a kid could just
click on all the way I mean now it's so
if I had a kid I'd be data be my most
like fear especially with a boy or a
girl doesn't matter it's just the wrong
click of a computer and he goes so dark
so and the kids eyes go from like boring
boring boring why but yeah our
grandfather was like this illustration
on the side of an aircraft well have my
drug all right like a few generations
which thought it was like a rock shaped
like a nipple like this yeah and now
like our like on German like [ __ ] on
another person like wow okay get off
without diarrhea I can't get off without
diarrhea that's what it is amazed you
[ __ ] on command yeah second is not gonna
work so i gotta work now here's the
cellophane i need you to put what where
did you learn that louie ck he's like
pornography z don't you think we have
enough of it is saying dan have we made
enough porn now we go [ __ ] okay we've
made enough porn we fill them but
they're still cranking out just volumes
and volumes of it every single day just
enormous amount of pornography in our
vests in the right word is enormous yeah
it's amazing it's amazing I mean kids
are just flooded with it there's no way
you can have a kid now without him
looking at porn there's no way I know
what do you do like there's nothing like
parental controls on like device they're
too young I mean I the most they can do
on the computer i will set a movie for
them or something you know and I i
deprive them the problem is that because
they are deprived of digital technology
they try and get more and try and figure
out how to work me over for like TV and
stuff but right yeah I I kind of just
don't do a lot of that young though yeah
yeah yeah commuters miners and kids it's
really just porn I mean computers I mean
that's the thing you got to keep away
from them I
no reason for a kid to have a computer
yeah no I mean well and I mean the games
are just like once they get going like
the big thing with Minecraft and
something they just sit there and their
brains they can't escape I have a hard
time putting my phone down so oh no
doubt were those games oh god yeah yeah
oh yeah oh they were worse I remember I
played for I think three days straight
gotta eat and all that [ __ ] what were
you playing some kid in China died like
a few weeks ago no forgot to eat forgot
to piss just played for three days date
and then just died it's always some
kidding I'm like there's there's gotta
be something wrong with the game if even
one person that was they were playing
while they had bird flu I been just have
to be something i don't know but i have
heard of guys playing for days and not
eating and and for some reason men are
more affected with those video games and
women i don't think women really care
too much but men and boys once they
start doing those games it you could do
that for days not any desire to kill
things probably or are puzzles I think
guys like puzzles and visual things and
visual puzzles I don't some scientists
know me yeah I don't know since I've
seen kids play those games four [ __ ]
days yeah days and the whole like
building levels and then yeah you know
can you and I I used to Danny for these
kits and they were really into World of
Warcraft this is like 10 years ago and
then you know what they were like kind
of loaded it's like they knew even it
like sex grain anything like had all
their parents like credit card
information and stuff yeah so they would
just buy up goodbye it look at like
level up oh sure you either like do the
level or by the level yeah yeah they
just start buying and I'm like oh my god
these rich families like they just leave
me the credit card based be like party
war damn credit card goes back with
minecraft block I spent a thousand
dollars on my trap they don't look
probably they probably don't know they
don't even know and then they be at the
problem that this goodnight a need for
had was a he'd make it up to these high
level because he's buy-in but then or
the other thing was you could pay
somebody to get you there
oh oh who could hey what's the point in
that somebody to get you higher but then
he'd go up there but he didn't know
anybody to play with like there was
nobody else oh really too high he was
too high at the level I'm like do it
because it was a you know hard yeah
whole reason you have to like to learn
their have to learn right not only are
they sitting around playing the game
being lazy they're paying someone else
else out the American Way you're still
unsatisfied cuz like they can't even get
the reward like that kid in China who
was willing to die die for that he's
crazy news value of the game yeah yeah
all those sick things I to spend money
on that [ __ ] is like gambling it's kind
of like you have such an empty feeling
after you lose blackjack and that's got
to be an empty feeling to be like oh I
spent a thousand dollars I'm a level
yeah yeah level of a game like [ __ ] went
to waste of money but you would rather
play on your phone and play like actual
games in vegas right i would rather do
that yeah i would rather do that games
in vegas a blackjack scares me because
i'm always next to somebody that's angry
with me because i'm not playing
correctly and so they all do some kind
of black jack move and then look at me
and be like you [ __ ] up the cards for
me some [ __ ] angry drunk you know
right and not only that but like I can't
stand it when i get a tie of a 20 and
then the dealer gets goddamn 21 that's
really annoying I just the [ __ ] him
yeah I got a 20 you got a 20 I did it
right right yeah I got a great thing
right 20 yeah and the deal is just like
oh sorry you know there's only one
[ __ ] combination that could beat me
and she gets it yeah and then she goes
do you play Vegas a lot um we'd like
perform their yeah yeah how much of a
gambler though I just like it I'll take
my chunk of money whatever is maybe like
100 bucks and then I'm happy to lose
that for the night yes I'm the same way
it's fun i love it but I mean if you
keep going back you're just like where
do you perform over there in Vegas um
well sometimes at the south point
there's a dirty show that that's really
fun a late night dirty show oh yeah it's
real
cool yeah um and that's that's the last
place where I was I actually recorded my
one hour special at southpoint at
southpoint what's up when it's like it's
self this point this point of this trip
kind of not like the fanciest casino but
a lot of locals come there and they
treated us like enemy so great there
I'll do that yeah and the stage was
really cool so it was a nice place to
shoot like in record oh that's cool yeah
Rachel that a son um it came out on hulu
about a year ago just oh yeah yeah I'm
really happy with it yeah that's Austin
an hour a whole hour wow that's great
that's a dad where the others are ya but
the best part about recording it is
getting rid of that our cuz you work all
those years to put that one hour
together and then yeah yeah i know i'm
done with that so now you gotta start
all right doesn't anymore yeah right
pretty much i'm pretty much good you
know if you set it right sometimes i do
songs and some songs people want to hear
again it's not look quite like this
there's a few like thank you do some
songs for us you want about my guitar oh
you did yeah oh my god for sure [ __ ]
that'd be great sure whatever you want
oh yeah I can have it anyway yeah yeah
some songs a little bit that's that's do
anything for us sure would be great
somebody with talent you don't know what
that is we have no idea what so we did
you and Ralphie be doing stand-up we met
and um well in Houston when I first
started it was an open mic I hadn't seen
him do stand-up but he was kind of like
King [ __ ] of turd Island over there and
he walked over like he was a hotshot I
before I performed it was kind of a dick
and some uh yeah he was kind of a dick
he was kind of like policing the open
mic you know and I got up and I had a
great first time like I'm amazing first
time and so afterwards he came over to
me and was like that was really funny
and he gave me his pager number I didn't
want to date a comic and I never thought
I would date anyway he was 800 pounds
back then so the idea of us dating was
like the furthest thing from my mind
yeah so we became friends and then we
got to know each other and we ended up
dating very like we became really good
friends so that's cool so he friends
first and then in that yeah like I mean
it wasn't a long friendship but it was
immediate like really good connection
yes that's good
and I I was so naive because like back
then I I was of the I you know I didn't
at first I was like there's no way I
date a fat guy like before him I'd only
did it fit guys in fact I hadn't it
makes me self I haven't had that many
boyfriends but the guy right before him
I climbed a mountain with him we went to
the Himalaya they got no time so Ralph
he hasn't done that yeah that would be I
would love for him to be able to that
he'd have to man I would love firms just
be able to like walk out to the bluff at
runyon I think that would be awesome
yeah but um but yeah it's been 17 years
and its really he's unhealthy at this
point cuz once you get to a certain age
yeah doesn't the wait and listen I
battle it you know my family and and
it's it's a difficult thing I I do it
every single day I try to talk to
nutritionists and and and it's you know
my dad was you know pretty big guy
really big guy so it's hereditary and
it's all kinds of stuff you know it's
it's tough there was very very
frustrating and tough you know to love
somebody you know like that and like I
was that with my father and it just you
know I requires a lot of patience and an
R alpha and everybody's part you know
and I think food is just part of it I
think I don't know for me I'm like huh
it's addiction yeah I when you get to
that size it's you know and it's hard
like yeah but he just has a hard time
with that it's just been really hard
like we start talking at the beginning
that we don't need to do therapy but
it's just been really hard lately and
you know i don't i don't know you just
don't want to watch somebody killed him
so no God no no but I love him I think
he's a wonderful guy and it's really
funny funny really funny talented sweet
person you just wish people would learn
to love themselves as much as everyone
else loves them yeah definitely God what
would the world be like if that happened
right uh-huh right you can pretty much
like point that to somebody so many
things well it's the thing in your brain
and you know you just gotta give
yourself a break yeah give herself a
[ __ ] huge break and yeah take it easy
on yourself it's tough it's tough and
God knows this [ __ ] country has
shitty food when you're [ __ ] turn
yeah you could walk out and get a
goddamn you know
fast food every goddamn corner it's
ridiculous it's hard to find the right
food all the time it's just if tire is
here on the road and you can't prepare
and that's a tough life yeah I mean he's
got a bus so he you know he can but I
just think there's you have to want to
yeah I think it comes down to loving
yourself and wanting to be yeah in it
too for you know for yourself and fruit
really yeah I am it's tough so anyway
well our prayers you know oh you know my
love him yeah huh shallow hal oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a good one he
helped like he did some punch up for
something I were waiting one day and I
guess like consulting with a fat man
yeah that's really fat man yeah tell us
no condom but so now you're in la most
of the time right yeah and and and doing
your thing here do you go where do you
go up here um I do the improv Allah and
the comedy store and I haven't I'm doing
irvine i'm headlining at revine this
week are ya some ya know in just one
night but yeah that's good night um
thursday but there's I've already that
already happened I love it I love that
irvine down there isn't it great bob is
awesome so it was an awesome night by
the time you play this cuz it's gonna be
fun it's like what is it tomorrow yeah
yeah but it's brand new down there cool
everything is like a new mommy what are
you like umami burger yeah you want a
burger we're gonna put everything on it
oh good so in that it's got it's just
they redid everything down there so it's
a really nice club yeah really nice club
I think it's eats like 3-400 Pete oh my
god its massive smash yeah that's gonna
be fun no it's really fun I do it every
couple of months they've been really
good to me they've been good down there
they're nice folks down there really
sure the improv is in general are
awesome because I mean they're all over
the place yeah yeah and they're all
great they're all in great areas for
sure I'm no doubt I felt really lucky
that's so cool and they are all they
have individual owners are they all like
one giant oh well I think that they're
owned by the the corporation you know in
bud and then I think they have their own
managers are they okay there's different
branches of it only by different like
there's certain partners but I don't
know exactly how it works either there's
yeah but once you're in one place it
helps places are not so much I don't
know I don't know how they work and I
think there's there's guys that get
booked all over I'm not sure how they
work it over there I really have no I
don't know this was hilarious who wants
to get broken I'm prom I don't know why
it's hard it's hard to get this book
there though no that's like a great
really high really fun yeah I'm right
like I said I feel really blessed how do
you like stand up Oh hate it I love it
it's a sick obsession right yeah just I
love it so much how long you been doing
it since I met my husband well that's
been like 17 years yeah you do a lot of
your guitar on stage I do I used to just
play songs and then but then I've I've
moved away from doing that it took me a
long time but I just put the guitar down
i'll talk a little bit and then the
guitars like the icing at the end so
yeah it's cool yeah it's fun it's a
great thing I love it and I've done it
for a little bit how long not long maybe
four years cuz I've seen you around yeah
I mean I've done it for like four years
here and there I just started doing i
come from second city in that so it's
improv basic I have a basic improv and
then I just started doing it for years
ago for five years ago yeah you kind of
did it around started when we started
the show yeah something like that yeah
yeah but I still have the same AG it's
addictive okay really I got a few other
job to do stuff that's normal no that's
normal in the first what's the normal
like like I've been doing it since 2011
maybe something like that or 2000 George
Carlin said if you write and this I mean
I think this is different for everyone
but one of his quotes I think I'm
probably to misquote it but it was like
five minutes a year which is that's all
right then it's / you think that it is
different the longer you're in it
because you're you just get to know how
to do things and get to build your voice
but yeah yeah no oh wow yes five minutes
per yeah and that's not true to everyone
I mean like Ralphie has 91 hour specials
so they
that's a lot he's prolific yeah you know
and everybody has their own thing for me
I write songs so i can write a little
faster it just depends on on who but I
mean I maybe he's talking about those
gold bits that are just well all of his
bits were really good you know and I
don't know how long he worked on them
but yeah like you know the the words you
can't say on TV and then all those bits
were each of those bids for like 20
minutes long George Carlin yeah that
advice man each one of those jokes was
about 20 minutes you know shed but
everybody starts at Oak open mic with a
few things and then you just kind of
grow from there and it takes everybody
liked a different amount of time
depending how many open mics I always
think that like the more I do stand-up
the more I realized that it's you might
have a good joke that you think you're
not really sure if it's good or bad you
know you don't know where it stands you
know on is it an all-star is it just in
the middle or really shitty and then
your job is to figure out if it's a good
joke and use that okay think I think you
start off thinking yeah I think it's a
good joke and then you try it out on a
few audiences and you get different
[ __ ] reactions from every single
audience the one thing I'll stand up is
it's really about the goddamn audience
he like did you have a good show well I
don't yeah the audience was good i mean
so they got it you know or they didn't
get it and does that mean my joke sucks
not necessarily right should I throw
that joke out I don't think so because
the other audience in the you know last
three audiences loved it but this one
hated it and then you know so you sit
there and go all right so whether or not
it takes about ten or a lot of shows to
figure out I'm going to keep that joke
because as a percentage I've killed with
it I've killed with it you know maybe
sixty percent of the times I've done it
so but it takes a lot of doing it over
and over again to see if it works you
know which is a pain in the ass that's
the hard thing and that's just one
[ __ ] bit or one joke that you think
is good you know yeah what's your
experience oh god I mean if if you know
something works just stick with it
because the audience get me wrong and
the early
times they are wrong you know there's
some jokes I love this I love a couple
of major I just love the joke and I
don't care if it doesn't work and i just
write to do a coup i like it cuz it's a
cute yeah and i think it's clever or
whatever you like doing it cuz sometimes
the joke like if i do a joke that might
be just like silly and that i enjoy
doing it and i think i left what will
get a laugh as if I'm like well [ __ ] you
people I like it yeah there's your laugh
on it which is almost just as good cuz I
agree I mean there's a lot of my act
that I just won't give up just cuz i
enjoy doing it yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean i was gonna like that nobody wants
one will not enjoying it I mean you want
to see well it's not a really enjoyable
when you have people look at any going
what the [ __ ] so you have to start up if
it like I have a few of those clunkers
that are so clunky that you have to
address the audience gone what the [ __ ]
are you doing up then you go you didn't
like that did you you didn't like that
at all did you I got some more yeah more
of that [ __ ] I got a lotta more of that
[ __ ] I got a lot more of that [ __ ] well
do you want to do some songs for sure
i'll be great I can't ya got you atara
set up nice gosh how nice it is then we
get off today usually it's look at that
case it's a case that's been around i
wish i could play i walk today sam ash
the other day and I just thought god
damn look at all this is fun instruments
like drums and guitars and it makes you
want to play oh can we do this Aaron
let's see o hearin ya can you help us
makes you want to play something but
then I realize I'm far too stupid dude
what's that thing with you you want to
play and then you try you like yeah but
if I couldn't do it I want to do it
everybody's had that moment oh do this I
starter ukulele in the corner of my
house like all the time yeah I try to
ukulele I've tried a ukulele I've tried
piano when I've tried harmonica yeah
failed at all mom wait how could you
fail harmonic I just failed I think I
got the old Susanna don't you cry for me
where I come from Alabama get out of
here than I through harmonica [ __ ] you I
Veronica I tried it in bad you know like
I listened to the recording going
alright that's enough like I'm gonna
watch TV you have to fight it it's harm
to I started when I was so young so my
parents spent a lot of money on guitar
lessons and are probably like deeply
regretting that decision because they
probably never dream that I'd be doing
it to play you know dirty songs so I
think I'm gonna like this I know 32
what's the first one well they're not
all dirty let's see which I do um this
is probably my favorite song to play
just because it's quick and this is a
duet between Anne Frank and Helen Keller
oh yeah here you go in Frank obviously
she's the Jew hiding in the Attic i'm
jewish and a helen keller couldn't see
couldn't hear but she was able to
communicate right right here you go
Oh
Shh
that's an excellent you can really see
it do that's weddin let's see I I have a
cup this is a I like playing new stuff
for me so it's not new yahoo but um this
is a song I wrote recently just about um
women lady bits as we age okay because I
think do i do you worry about your lady
bits yeah yeah I worry about him I do
what's gonna happen I have a friend one
of my friends in vag it's a apparently
there's something called vaginal rehab
where apparently her vagina is falling
apart and like she goes and gets the
finger banged and I don't know so i can
do that yeah it's a good how you do his
finger girl just like a tight net
tighten it around right yeah all day
long just I could hang a shingle up like
you want to pick my own fix your giant
get on in here and just finger girls
that's that's there's a profession you
know yet you could do that I'm in how
big are your finger to goddamn hand I
don't know if they want big fingers are
like little little Thai boys because
really it's it's a good idea a probably
a whole like rainbow guy who has this
job i think i would imagine you'd want a
really tiny like et finger because you
want to tighten around things for every
guy that's it's a really good idea on
paper but then you know you get like
five good ones and then a rule that's
why it comes in and wreak so bad okay I
don't want to do the same yeah the job
the lure of that profession flies out
the window you can't choose your
clientele no no you can't come in she
goes you finger me know retinol therapy
to know it's not marry me
well honey like a finger condom yeah
you're like let me put my mask on for
this one yeah okay cuz your [ __ ] smells
like a bola the truth is you just look
at her go what do you need it for anyhow
let's be like what do we need let it go
let it go so I was okay here we go I
began to think i was looking fine when a
hot boy smiled at me I'm married so I
want to be clear I wouldn't have acted
seriously but that innocent flirt ended
up crushing my esteem that day cuz he
waved at my kids and he called me ma'am
and he turned and walked away oh no i
SAT there dejected feeling very lame
then it occurred to me all [ __ ] needs a
new PR campaign Oh his recycle do not be
confused my brother you know the truth
it's better when it's used to ha ha ha
micro California recycle the muffler is
good the engine purrs too who cares
about dense never should buy new kids
might mess it up all it needs is love
like your favorite old t-shirt or a beta
baseball glove it's a [ __ ] up visual
but it works for right many things get
better with age like cars wine boats &
boos so tap Mama's ass cuz it's better
when it's used Oh
find yourself a cougar do not throw away
like meatloaf or lasagna it's always
better than next day hahahaha smile so
just turn out the light like sexual
prime aged steak with a touch of
cellulite if you find yourself a milf
you're gonna have some fun and the best
part they'll be cookies and milk when
you're done cuz it's better it's better
when it's you
recycle I love it I love it that's so
cool I think we're hitting him I think
we're hitting a new movement about lady
parts being celebrated yeah at a later
stage in life yeah kind of a movement
know wherever you read about it as we
get about that why do you think that's
gonna I'm gonna make it I don't know
we're lately part in general there's
like a nice you know I mean yes there's
the crazy side of things I think in
general like society is becoming more
accepting of do you feel that there's a
celebration of old balls 2 i'll get on
the same page here celebrating the wrong
pair of nuts that oh yeah aging is sad
and it sucks hey Doc oh great about it I
mean we get wiser oh why don't wiser
that doesn't help anyone's makes you
bitter it does duh I see the hill at
this point in my 30s I know more than I
want to know about what I was definitely
more confident more daring you know like
it was a more fun person when I was 18
yeah oh yeah I like I was just because
we didn't know so much [ __ ] mmhmm yeah I
didn't have any responsibility yeah yeah
that was awesome care and you know you
just afraid of losing energy right yeah
like five whatever endeavor I go into
now I my first thought is I'm not gonna
have enough energy to do that you know
what I mean it's like hey you want to go
I've was a couple drinks or you want to
meet us for you know go to a movie and
I'm like do I have enough energy for a
movie why are you through this can I get
a min am I gonna make it through this I
don't know my husband I went to fyf
which is a fast [ __ ] yeah fest it was
down at us see ya at USC this weekend or
Expo exposition park and you know it's
one of these like it's like Coachella
you know there's all these different
stages and all these things we park our
car we look up where to park and and and
so they say oh yes fyf parking over here
so we
Park and then like we're walking like we
could see signs and like we realized
we've now been walking pretty close to
two miles to get to the entrance now
this is the beginning God where you're
gonna stand on your feet for the next
like turn around and go home I mean
seriously we kind of should have because
yeah it was sober and then like you know
the distance between each stage so we
look at me like okay Solange is here now
but we want to get over to see Belle and
Sebastian and then come back in time for
Morrissey and you were like doing more
suit here yeah more students there and
you know d'angelo and fka twigs and the
whole thing and like we're like mapping
out and then we realize like we gotta
get back to the car it's two miles [ __ ]
me man I'm not why I I like to hike it's
different than hiking though standing on
the Congress like super hard right yeah
I thought I did know it's like you know
you're like on paper you going festival
fun music [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah festival
drinking fun cool now they don't tell
you about the two mile walk the traffic
jam after that and they and how old your
body is old your [ __ ] body is i said
i watch you can't [ __ ] like Coachella
great idea and paper but I would the
only way i would go is in a camper in
line yeah you got it just gotta be like
I'm at the point my life where I need a
VIP I need to be IP for every day Tim
you don't know what the IP feels like so
you're late alright yeah exactly you
don't even know yeah I won't take a
fight it's like well if I get first
class I mean right so the sock even now
you know but on my concerts out of the
question it was a great [ __ ] seeds
you know that I am I can somebody will
me in right you could be on a gurney can
occur oh my god you know like go to how
about Disney you gotta go to Disney
lines ah no no the reward is not worth
the exertion of any that should be how
VIP it should be you get a bed like you
basically get wheeled around ad somebody
will you in the
us you get a you get an attendant we
should all go to concerts when we are
like geriatric and you just get pushed
around the concert and rolling but
you're like I'm red how would be the way
to do sellers was gonna get me a little
rascal and just knowing even sporting
events too I'm like watch it on TV
because it's much more enjoyable if I
have to sit there and worry about
whether or not my knee is gonna go out
on the way back to the car and I just
know it does not that's a legitimate
concern because it said it's on the
table this is not fabrication like there
isn't she I was worried my knees were
gonna go out to ya [ __ ] I mean what it
takes away from the joy of seeing Morris
yeah for sure yeah but that he was
looking so old oh jesus oh hey look was
he look so old he said not he puts his
leg up on the he pretends like he's
doing literally some some stretching oh
oh oh he's sweating bullets he's in this
leg blu-ray all-grain just kind of like
a little bit like soft like so that's
already know like the people you think
you remember like oh my god yes i was
watching vh1 and I saw like new order or
something oh yeah yeah and I looked like
whoa whoa guys are all old old old yeah
leg up on the speaker he's just kind of
like hate I honestly look he just had to
take a minute like course you needed a
minute just kind of be both hands on
there yeah you can edit on taking over
is like Mick Jagger all these old rock
and roll guys that are still dressing
like good guys wear a blazer hey go to
what some regular at this point you're
70 you're 70 we can still pull up a
pretty good show i figure yeah yeah but
I mean you're 70 yeah you're wearing a
jeans from a 20 or make jack yeah yeah
at some point I don't care you you gotta
slip in a blazer you can't what do you
know gotta slip into Haggar slacks erato
you just [ __ ] got it because your 80s
you know man who has our pants I let it
hold man in leather
pants and it's like well I'm not old yet
yeah you are you actually were five
years ago and you gotta wear like Haggar
slacks oh my god is god oh that's what's
so funny what if like what if Jerry ajik
fashion became leather pants and it just
changed too ok guess our generation
grows this is how we do it okay dude
yeah i'll tell you what like um no i
live in laurel canyon and there's like
all the canyon moms are all x actresses
and models and they're all beautiful and
you show people event and the moms are
like super hot wearing like leather
pants okay like do this is not like any
other elementary school yeah you don't
you feel bad you're super hot well thank
you but it's just like I don't you're
one of them yeah Canyon mom I guess you
are I will say like leather pants and
dressing like your 20s is okay when your
30s your 40s your 50s half of your
sixties half of your six days and then
when you reach 66 boom you're done
you're done you're [ __ ] done you're
done lady no more leather pants no guys
no more to kabhi chels take it all off
take it [ __ ] all off the earrings all
of it goes at 67 here's the real chassis
7077 it Mick Jagger though you gotta be
like me I guess yeah I think he was
amazed yes I think I think he looks
foolish she's hey how did you feel when
McDonald walks around in the like skimpy
skimpy stuff because she's like no does
the hot body but it doesn't work like
they used to oh no point it feels she's
like here's what I think I think that
the only thing age gives you is dignity
you've lived it you you're still on the
planet you're still here you're still
walking around you can tell you know out
of just for the sheer fact of living you
can tell a lot of people hey I know
about that just because you've lived
that gives you that gives you a gold
star see a ticket but that's dignified
you know what I mean and unless you just
been adduced your whole life gonna do
[ __ ]
haven't even opened up your eyes and you
Benedict you're like usually just living
gives you some kind of knowledge and
dignity so to dress like you're 20 it
doesn't make sense that this it just
doesn't make sense to me she's been
there done that but I'm saying also just
because the one thing youth have is
their bodies they're hot you know young
bodies and so they can show it off in
cool clothes they can show it off
wearing cool clothes and when you're
[ __ ] old I'm sorry balls are drooping
down to my knees right [ __ ] I got 10
secs mad I'm wearing I'm wearing a
blazer cover you like a skinny pants
white t-shirt yeah and when you do it
only makes me think there's something
wrong with you there's something [ __ ]
wrong like there's something
disconnected cuz I does I don't think
that it's cool I think I immediately go
this is something wrong with you I mean
look at your balls look at you come on
oh yeah I don't know we gotta get going
but um we have timing real quick about
in your hideout sketch yes let's read
what yes I just did that yesterday just
came out um we'd shot a sketch that was
a parody but you know did you see the
movie did you get I did yes oh so Riley
the little girl what happens when she
grows up it's kind of nice yeah just
Bing bong the character in it yeah every
Disney movie they have to kill somebody
no thank you her childhood friend
although he's creepy a little bit yeah I
mean it's Richard kind so he's always a
little bit great yeah bori wanted to
find out what would happen if Bing bong
came back to riley in a a drug trip yeah
because that's when your sub-conscience
comes open and so if you guys get a
chance click on it cuz it we're now
watching it will tweet it out today it's
really cool i'm your night out really
prob looks great it's great pronoun yeah
yeah right yeah yeah awesome how those
actors are so funny so good lots of good
comics in it Joe Michelle was in it she
played discussed and doing a harder play
sorry fear no party stars oh my god
everyone is great like you gotta check
it out yeah absolutely Lana this has
been such a pleasure everybody she's on
our network Big Ten a perfect and
imperfect tense sorry a perfect mpaka
went to Madison way to go [ __ ] off
[ __ ] burbot 10 podcast and then um
let's see you're on the road a lot yeah
you can just go check me out on name
spot lah na Lana Turner to our anglers
you can find the online follow me on
Twitter all that kind of stuff and all
I'm you can find me ok perfect what a
pleasure thank you so much nobody yeah I
come back again soon please any all
right awesome thank you thanks again
thanks Darren our producer and
everything everybody else here at all
things comedy love you see you guys